so as some of you may know when I saw
Captain America at the screening that
didn't show The Avengers teaser because
I found out they weren't showing it at
any of the critics screening more than
likely because of the people who leaked
it online and they wrote it for
everybody so thanks for that guys for
last night after I saw
friends-with-benefits I decided to run
into the Captain America theatre at the
very end and see the Avengers teaser
finally now before I get into my
thoughts a lot of times people ask me
about random movies dude are you pumped
through that and I'm like not really I
should probably show you a trailer or
something first I mean I can hear about
different movies that are coming up and
I think oh that sounds neat but I have
to see footage from it first unless it's
a sequel coming off of a successful
first film like The Dark Knight Rises I
was pumped for that as soon as it was
announced so now that I've seen the
Avengers teaser I can officially say
that that looks frickin awesome
Joss Whedon is directing it and he is
like fanboy king heaven Firefly serenity
you know all different types of things
that people Buffy the Vampire Slayer a
lot of things people love and really
what it treats me as I was able to see
all of these characters that are already
established in previous films as you
know likeable characters together
interacting with each other and I was
like oh that's awesome
they showed Robert Downey jr. kind of
walk up to Thor and be like yeah you got
a mean swing there buddy yeah a mean
swing and I was like that's awesome I
mean to see those two characters that we
already like interacting is like oh that
that's that is really cool
so in this trailer you could see Captain
America and his Avengers outfit it's a
Hawkeye Iron Man Thor Nick Fury and even
get to see Mark Ruffalo a little bit as
banner really the main thing that I
would think would be very difficult to
make work in this film is so many huger
than life characters all in one movie I
can imagine it'd be really hard to
balance all of that I honestly think
it's gonna be awesome I'm really looking
forward to it I'm still more fun for
Dark Knight Rises simply because you
know I love Christopher Nolan and
there's previous two films were
excellent all of his movies are
excellent so yeah that's my thoughts
when the Avengers trailer thing it's
gonna be really awesome when I saw the
trailer I was like I'm a fanboy right
now so next week I'm seeing Cowboys and
Aliens on Tuesday look forward to that
day